entrez dans la danse celle du sculpteur
schaaf taille de ses filles et
chorégraphe de grandes oeuvres qui
appelle au toucher un mélange de métal
et de bois
un héritage son père travailler aussi
cette matière j'aime sa résistance sa
sensualité et je le mari avec métal
parce que ça me permet des techniques
des techniques différentes
elle boit et alan évolue progressivement
le métal il faut savoir où l'on voit et
on emploie des outils plus violents
c'est du feu des étincelles schaaf
taille est l'un des neuf artistes de ce
nouveau salon des lauréats cinq peintres
quatre sculpteurs prix mêlant des deux
dernière biennale de
voisins-le-bretonneux les prix ils sont
donnés une partie par le jury donc on a
un juré à chaque fois qu'il y soit une
oeuvre en particulier soit une mention
spéciale pour un univers et il ya un
prix du public à chaque chaque
exposition
le but du salon des leurs et à ses
clients tout cas qu'ils aient tous la
possibilité de mieux montrer leur
univers puisque les biennales en général
sont limités à trois au maximum chacun
près de 90 oeuvres sont présentées à la
maison de covile laurent chat selon lui
confie au public ses rêves
je me fais plaisir tout simplement un
joueur je met l'humain dedans forcément
parce que bon ben j'ai toujours aimé le
figuratif donc le figuratif se retrouve
dans mes peintures mais c'est pas
forcément que le figuratif qui
m'intéressent l'abstrait nous permet de
rentrer différemment dans ma peinture je
pense que le spectateur rentre également
par s'oublier la des univers multiples
des légendes des voyages les artistes
sont à découvrir ou à redécouvrir
jusqu'au 31 mars